what is his moose fights back what is
this the two me's bucking just wait for
it bro
[ __ ] that car up
locking horns
dude the sound of that is brutal oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
yeah let's break this fight now
geez Louise get out of my [ __ ] truck
I thought that was in the video for a
second yeah these boys had I don't know
what's the equivalent for like alcohol
with with mis
um tree sap
yeah cocaine Bear yeah yeah it's a
little yeah I was thinking something
more dark like they just what do what do
mice eat what does a moose eat I don't
know let's look it up herbivores oh okay
yeah are they really how much you want
to bet these moose eat wild mushrooms
and are just tripping balls or they run
out into the [ __ ] road yeah probably
that's what I run right at the car yeah
like Valhalla
I see you
[Laughter]
many types will dine on psychedelic
mushrooms bro let's go no way let's go
let's go
holy [ __ ] I just picture those two dudes
like splitting like eight like whatever
they can take 80 grams yeah yeah and
they're just [ __ ] getting into a bar
fight this guy's driveway
what do they think they're doing though
um it's a good question like what are
they seeing
I don't think anyone like chooses
violence on mushrooms you know maybe
they think each other is something else
coming at them yeah you know it's a
weird
like one of those horrible mushroom
stories where someone like smashes their
face in with a rock yeah observers
report that after eating the fungi deer
often act drunk by running around
aimlessly
twitching their heads and making noises
dog that's it that is for it they see
all those lights in the distance and
they say yo I wanna I wanna lick that
and yeah exactly
like a moth
hey yo a moose high as hell like I want
to put my tongue on that yeah running
right up to a train
eating these mushrooms infuses the
caribou's urine with psychoactive agents
meaning that the urine can and is
consumed for a high dude we need to find
some Caribou urine seriously
today Cody Noel do caribou urine
let's just do that and see if we can
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah I don't think it'd
be like that let me just be on our backs
like
and puking
Caribou will battle each other to earn
access to the urine of a herd mate that
has what fly agaric in its system oh
in noticing this uh Siberian tribes
realize that they too could benefit from
drinking this this spiked Caribou you're
holy [ __ ] humans have been getting high
forever yeah man
you sound like Joe for a second
it's true
I mean humans have been getting high
forever I mean just think about the
Siberian tribes for example they used to
drink spiked Caribou urine yeah they
used to drink Caribou urine and they get
really high and [ __ ] each other up it's
crazy yeah oh
edit with Miley Cyrus yeah definitely
[ __ ] it's so funny oh
you know
oh I know dude I want some Caribou you
damn we gotta find that
we should do Cody and no I'll do like
the weirdest drugs
didn't yo sorry that Tech Nine needs to
come back that song Caribou Lou yeah
big Caribou come 151 I don't remember
the [ __ ] lyrics that's one of the
songs that plays on my phone it's like
it's like d it's like in my iTunes
library from 10 years ago yeah
when my Bluetooth connects it'll be like
[Music]
dude that's so funny yeah because
I was asking Alex
my production assistant if he's ever
heard of tech N9 he's like no not really
and I said oh man
when this song came out [ __ ] college
kids went crazy for this [ __ ] and the
fact that you're like oh yeah no that's
just in my phone but it was before
College wasn't it a few years yeah yeah
but I think I found that song in like
high school like no yeah it was high
school but I feel like it still carried
you know yeah I think that was like a
lingering what was what was the story
behind Tech Nine
I I actually don't know much about them
I just know that there came a point
where
his crowd was very like uh blended with
a lot of crossover with ICP oh yeah so
you kind of became embraced by those
people right right did you no you went
to athletic School you had Juggalos at
your school no no Juggalos I had you
yeah really it was like three or four
like super hardcore at CSUN no in high
school oh wow okay regularly come to
school no way face paint really oh yeah
like clown face paint yep oh my God yep
Hatchet Man t-shirts and chains it was
about it Faygo
uh don't think we sold Faygo in my area
I don't think that they have that in
California do they no
definitely a Midwest thing
that's crazy or parts of West
so they liked
ICP that much uh they did it's not like
they light it was like it was going to
take a personality lifestyle dude life
wow yeah
they would uh
yeah it was their uniform and then they
would get in trouble for the face paint
so then they would only wear it on
Halloween
okay when Halloween came around you I I
could name drop them so quick that's so
funny
so you guys are all wearing masks today
but me this is when I just get to be me
yep
yep
a thousand Halloween is when I take my
mask off yeah this is the real me I'll
show you the real cycle that I am
that's [ __ ] awesome is there a better
name for a fandom than Juggalo but you
know what's crazy it's so sick they were
like two of the nicest dudes in school
these two guys yeah yeah no no the two
Juggalos oh yeah yeah
willing to engage anybody okay and
everybody knew him
well I mean is ICP like aren't they like
vaguely like Christian no and it's not
but it's not like violent music is it
I don't really know their music I just
know like part of one song and it's
pretty graphic what goes on this oh okay
yeah I'm not gonna brand them all as
violent I think they're mostly
well-mannered people they just kind of
like are to their own yeah
but the content of their lyrics I think
definitely it doesn't I don't know if it
promotes violence but this is some
brutal [ __ ] in there okay I'm not trying
to tiptoe I just don't know enough to
speak on Juggalo music
I feel like we that's yeah I'm just
saying No Name juggalo
I'm just saying we need Caribou you yeah